Apple completely shocked the tech
industry back in 2020 with the release
of their new M1 MacBook Air which
instantly became the best value laptop
you could buy thanks to its thousand
dollar price tag and the game-changing
M1 chip which is still very powerful to
this day now on the flip side in 2023
Apple hit us with the news that their
Max sales in the first quarter are down
40 compared to last year the worst drop
in 23 years now while there are multiple
reasons for this like a slowing down
economy one thing is for certain Apple's
M2 Max are not selling as well as they
hoped and I think it's got something to
do with how good the M1 MacBook Air was
and still is today so in this video I'm
going to explain what caused the failure
of Apple's redesigned M2 MacBook Air as
well as how the M1 model fears in 2023
especially with the news of the new M3
model coming in the fall so let's get
started in terms of what made the
original M1 MacBook Air so special there
were three fundamental aspects the first
one was the price being only 999 dollars
which had a fairly low barrier to entry
for the common student or person needing
a reliable and high quality laptop and
the MacBook Air was just that thanks to
the switch to an Apple silicon chip
which greatly improved reliability
alongside the metal build quality
excellent keyboard trackpad and display
the second aspect was the fact that for
only a thousand dollars you're getting a
huge jump in performance compared to the
previous Intel chip and both single and
multi-core performance impacting
everything from web browser snappiness
to productivity work in some apps it
even outperformed the higher end MacBook
Pros with Intel chips and it had just
enough performance to actually run
professional apps quite well the Third
third aspect was everything else the
Apple silicon chip brought to the
MacBook Air specifically features like
instant on which is a game changer
compared to previous Intel models that
took some time to wake up from sleep
another big one was the fanless design
which was mind-blowing considering the
high amount of performance meaning you
get a completely silent experience no
matter what and what makes it even
better is that no fans means no dust
clogging the fans and heat sinks over
time which would lead to unexplained
overheating and Loud fan issues on
previous Intel MacBooks but not with the
new M1 MacBook Air basically making it
much more reliable over the long term
and then going even further the most
impressive upgrade with the M1 chip was
the battery life which was mind-blowing
considering everything else that
improved like the performance being over
four times faster than the previous
Intel model in terms of gaming
performance and over three times fast
faster in terms of the CPU and the crazy
thing was that Apple's 13-inch MacBook
Pro was priced 300 higher but only
offering a couple of advantages like
better battery life and extra Graphics
core a fan for cooling and a touch bar
that nobody liked anyway we even modded
our own MacBook Air with a thermal pad
on the heatsink and that made it even
faster than the MacBook Pro in some
cases and over the next couple of years
every single Windows laptop we compared
to the air failed in terms of
performance value and battery life and
now that we're in 2023 the M1 MacBook
Air is now on sale on Amazon for only
800 brand new continuing to be the best
value laptop you can buy so with all
that said it's easy to see why the M2
MacBook Air didn't sell so well seeing
as it had such large shoes to fill and
there's also the fact that anyone who
bought the M1 was so satisfied with it
that they saw no reason to upgrade to
the M2 air redesign but it was actually
Apple who shot themselves in the foot
for a couple of different reasons the
first reason was the fact that they made
the M1 way too good especially in terms
of the performance in hindsight Apple
probably should have down clocked the
original M1 chip just a little bit so
that they could unleash that power in
the M2 Chip to make it look like a
bigger upgrade because to be honest the
M2 Chip just wasn't a big upgrade
performance wise compared to M1 at least
not enough to get people to feel like
they were missing out the M1 was still
more than good enough now the second
reason is that they actually downgraded
different components of the M2 MacBook
Air despite raising the price to twelve
hundred dollars the biggest one is the
fact that they switched from a dual Nan
and SSD chip configuration down to a
single chip which had various impacts to
Performance including SSD speeds
becoming up to two times slower that by
itself made transfer speed slow down but
the worst part was that the base model
only came with eight gigs of RAM which
fills up very quickly so what Mac OS
does is it borrows storage space from
the SSD and uses it as temporary Ram
which is a method called swap memory
however since the SSD speed was
drastically slowed down due to only
having one Nan chip the speed of the
swap slows down as well this basically
caused the new empty MacBook Air to be
slower than the old M1 air in various
tasks whenever the 8 gigs of RAM is full
which only takes about 10 chrome tabs to
be open in the background so whoever
made the call at Apple to switch to just
one nand ship May made a bad mistake and
they should have paid extra money to
make sure they had two nand chips now on
top of that since the MacBook Air is
fanless it heavily relies on the passive
heatsink for cooling and the M2 MacBook
Air actually removed the physical large
heat seek block entirely compared to the
previous M1 air now relying on a thin
graphene sheet for cooling this
basically caused the M2 Chip to overheat
faster than the M1 does and then finally
the speakers actually got downgraded on
the MCU air compared to the M1 having
toned down tweeters so Apple made all of
those downgrades while at the same time
increasing the price by 200 and the
worst part is that you can now find an
M1 model on sale for eight hundred
dollars and that brings me back to the
question of how the M1 air fares in 2023
and the answer is honestly quite well in
my honest opinion even though I know the
M3 MacBook Air is coming around the
corner in the fall I know the price will
once again be twelve hundred dollars and
even though the M3 chip will be very
fast and it'll improve battery life I
also know that 400 more is a lot to pay
over the M1 model so the question is
will those improvements be worth four
hundred dollars honestly for regular
people no the M1 is already very
efficient and more than fast enough for
the majority of people out there it's
very reliable lightweight and it still
works great now for Tech enthusiasts I
will definitely recommend they wait for
the M3 air because they're the ones who
care about the little details especially
the awesome new redesign but for those
who can't wait for the M3 and you're
okay paying a bit more money for the M2
model right now I'll suggest that you
should wait until June for Apple 15-inch
M2 MacBook Air Model which will be a
great deal for the display size and it's
going to have the best battery life out
of any laptop ever we already have
confirmation for multiple sources like
Mark German Ming Chico other Korean
leakers and even tsmc that the M3 chip
will not be ready and coming to the
15-inch MacBook Air so keep that in mind
so with all that said even in 2023 the
M1 air is still the best bang for the
buck laptop ever made at only 800 and
it's an instant recommendation for
anyone looking for a reliable and high
quality laptop now if you disagree with
me let me know down in the comment
section below but if you enjoyed it
click that Circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
all right